so our next guest is a grammy-nominated
musician concert master and music
professor he's also the founder of the
Long Island vegetable Orchestra that's
right it's the country's first and for
some reason only vegetable orchestra you
heard that right please welcome dr. Dale
stuck in Brock first of all let me
establish stuck in Brock is your real
name is that correct I think so yes your
name is dr. stuck and Brock I'll look at
them okay all right what do I asked you
are classically trained yes you're a
classically trained musician when did
you start playing with vegetables and
trying to turn them into musical
instruments about 2005 I was trying to
get students to think about music in a
different way in a non-traditional way
so that they would really love it okay
give us some idea cuz a lot of people
just don't understand I'll be admitted
MIT I'm one of them the first instrument
you ever made was a carrot flute a
carrot flute yes alright would you like
to show us first of all to start us out
or an instrument that you would like to
show us and demonstrate how a vegetable
can become an instrument wonderful the
most convincing one that changed my
taste actually of eating was by hearing
the broccoli okay let me just show this
first this is a stalk of broccoli and
then as you can see you've hollowed out
the center and jammed a carrot in there
and you've made some holes right here if
I describe this instrument properly
perfectly anyone can do that yes go
ahead doctor stuck in brook yes make
magic there we go
[Music]
that's beautiful
[Applause]
that's that is it's effective it now do
you eat the vegetable after you're done
performing with it that's the deal okay
is it really the deal that you have with
your students yes it is when I first
started off you you have to make it and
they need it ok that's it because you're
promoting good health as well correct
that was before lunch ok you also made I
think what else would you make you made
a leek violin is that right yes I did
and it's right here and it's sounds I
don't know about that one I was I really
love this that sounds like mice doing it
[Applause]
ok what's next you have a slide carrot
I'm told a slide carrot and you're gonna
actually play a song for us on the slide
carrot yes what are you gonna play oh it
would something Irish should be lovely
or anything else yeah I'll go with that
sure ok yeah you know Danny Boy yes I do
okay let's do Danny Boy what's Kiwi in
boy I'm gonna stop this you sounded good
I was what key worried in there I wasn't
sure what key we were in see okay you
could just say anything you were just
blowing you're just pulling through a
carrot you can say whatever you want
tell me describe what it's like doctor
stuck in brook when you're in the
vegetable section say of your local
store and people see you hollowing out a
carrot and then blowing into it do
people ever think that this is unusual
behavior well yes I'm sure but it's the
ideal performance space for a vegetable
musician so you have actually played in
the grocery store yes okay and they
don't interfere it anyway they see a
customer gouging holes into the
vegetables and then more or less
molesting them and then they allow you
to just go about your way no one has
ever stopped me I've wondered about that
I love that no one has ever stopped me
okay what about squeakers what are
squeakers that's one of your specialties
yes and my favorite if I may say because
your favorite of the instruments yes
because in my orchestras you know you're
not allowed to squeak so in a real
Orchestra you're not allowed to squeak I
say you're kicked out so I love this for
that reason so we have different
squeakers and different squeaking
possibilities you know
yes and
the magic trough how have you not been
arrested I'd understand don't understand
here stop it stop it you please stop it
I understand you have a butternut-squash
which serves as the brass section that's
correct
um and it has a trumpet mouthpiece on
top you painted and you painted a little
figure on this yes it's it's it sounds
the way it looks
please go ahead yes I like how midway
through you look to me for approval is
this
is this okay is there a vegetable that
you've had no luck with that just
doesn't work its side from some of the
ones we just saw
Wow
I'm going to help it you're coming with
me together and we'll have plenty of
roughage so a vegetable that just hasn't
worked for you well the most
embarrassing
vegetables are this weekís my favorite
yeah but sometimes they just don't work
yes I saw yeah
and finally you have a marimba that you
wanted to show us you put a lot of work
into yes it's this is made of
hollowed-out carrots yes it's a
Vietnamese dan trunkman test oh very
nice I have to say I think you may have
started with the best instrument I
thought that was I thought this was
fantastic this was great and then but
they're all amazing it's amazing that
you've done this and and you're teaching
children about the value of good food
and good music right
you